ceo man you have the most this has been
from st though she got the most what's
up ben a
and st louis i don't know who is saint
louis actually
all
right saint louis
or louis the
nine
commonly known as saint louis
or lewis the saint was king of france
from 1226 to 1270 and the most
illustrious
of the direct captions he was crowned in
the reams
at age 12.
there you go
people i guess that's who he was baby
louis the nine
that's it
from posse france damn
well
yeah
there you go baby that's it dog if you
from posse
you must be
you a real you're a real g in my book
that's for sure so i'm not shocked he
was a saint
um
what else do we have oh it was a call
that came in my bad let's hear more this
is ben from st though she's got the most
acute
baby syndrome in a man i've ever seen
you were talking to bryce in that
interview and you compared winning a
fight and the will to win a fight
to whether or not a man is going to have
children
you need a baby theo but your life is
too busy you might be a homosexual i
don't know
and you don't have a
wife yet
well look man i would like to have a
baby
okay but i can't have a baby with just a
penis brother
so that's first part
if i was homosexual dog
i would know
you know what i'm saying i've never
looked at the back of a man
i've never looked at the back of a man
like that if a man
even if i see a man who's painting or
doing something
and you see part of his butt a little i
don't even
you know i got a buddy
and he would uh
he told me one time and this is he told
me in secrecy but he's dead
uh
he said when he would see a man's butt
crack he would imagine nipples on his
butt
you know like titty nipples and i don't
even do that man so
if i'm ever thinking about something
naked it's so it's it's female
but
you never know
if i get hit by lightning or something
you never know or if i
i might
you never know you might fall in love
with you could somebody could come
across you that changes you you changes
your game
somebody could come across and you just
say you know what
sayonara [ __ ]
and you go for it so
uh as of now
i have no inkling to believe that but
you know if god wants it god wants it
baby let's hear more
well i do
i propose to you
that you impregnate my wife will raise
the child
will agree upon a price and you can see
him when you want to see him st louis is
pretty close to you five six hours uh
you know a price
so now basically you get you trapping me
in the f
so it's my kid i'm pregnant with the
wife
and then
but who pays who that'd be my question
because i'm you know what i'm saying i'm
running this high dollar root sauce over
here
i'm running this high dollar freaking uh
this wand uh chowder
so if you out you know
i got that real uh stick venom baby you
know what i'm saying i could sell dude i
could sell this
i could and my stuff's thick too i got
that preserves
so i could i'm sure
i could get a little dollar for this
so i'm just saying who's paying who
you know we need a passive source of
passive income
you need a son bud
okay so i'm paying you're saying you
need a source of passive income i need a
son but i'm not keeping my son you know
i don't want to have this you know this
song where you go see him like he's in a
stable or whatever
so
i appreciate it man you know i guess
could i impregnate that guy as a wife
i don't think i could man i mean i could
try
but that's the crazy part if she and i
meet up at a damn days in or whatever
and you let me try and then it doesn't
happen
[ __ ] maybe
maybe i'll do that dude
dude i'll just meet up and try with her
for a couple hours dude or even four
even 50 even 17 minutes
so anyway man uh i love you guys and
thank you for the opportunity man thank
you for the opportunity and i'll let you
know if i need some of that
but yeah i've been thinking about maybe
it would be nice to have a wife you know
i need i'm definitely get because my
friends are all settling down
you know andrew schultz just got married
chris deleah is married bernie shaw's
married
i mean even just the
the dumbest people i know are married
so i'm like if they can do it i can do
it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one